Hey, do you know that Project 2025 might ban video games?
Uh, yeah, right.
That just scare tactics.
They're actually talking about cracking down on degenerate culture.
And guess what's top of mine?
Your games? Come on,
they're not banning call of duty.
They wouldn't do that. Well,
they think that games like that are promoting violence and moral decay.
But hey, don't take my word for it.
They're actually talking about monitoring your media consumption.
Media consumption? You know,
stuff like tracking the games you buy,
the content that you watch.
Maybe check your social media posts for on American activity.
I despise my games. Noob.
They wouldn't do that. Oh,
but they love surveillance.
I mean,
imagine them accessing your game history to see what you're playing.
Maybe flag if you're playing anything too violent or,
I don't know, Liberal.
Like Zelda. Zelda
what? Oh,
and let's not forget internet usage.
They might actually start tracking that too.
You know, just to protect you from dangerous influences,
like what sites you're visiting.
You know, if they're going to ban porn,
they're going to have to enforce that somehow.
By spying on you. Doesn't matter to me, dude.
I don't even eat corn, let alone watch it.
Well, project 2025 is all about controlling immoral behavior.
Nothing's off the table if it doesn't fit with their agenda.
So they could just watch what I do on my phone at night
and in the morning? Yeah,
they sure can. I Thought this was about,
you know, freedom of choice.
Sure, as long as your choices match with their values.
Otherwise, they'll be right there watching